hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for
anime operor and today i will be
breaking down
the latest developments in the direct
sequel to the seven deadly sins
the four knights of the apocalypse the
identity of the four
knights has just been confirmed for at
least three of them
although we have a pretty good guess
about who the fourth one is as well
not only that but percival's epic magic
was just revealed and it was heavily
implied
that king arthur and merlin might be
evil now
i mean i highly doubt it but that seems
to be where the story wants to lead us
and we even saw a return of chaos power
oh man there is so much to talk about so
let's get into it
if you enjoyed the seven deadly sins and
knights of the apocalypse content
on this channel and you want to see more
please leave a like
and comment it really does help and i'm
not just saying that the way that
youtube works if you like and comment
you are supporting this video
in the youtube algorithm and of course
if you are new to anime outpour don't
forget to subscribe and hit
that notification bell to turn on all
notifications
unless you do that right now you're
gonna miss a lot of our videos
in the future finally this video will of
course contain four nights of the
apocalypse manga spoilers so please
proceed with caution you have been
warned
okay so i covered the first three
chapters of the sequel manga
in two previous videos so if you haven't
seen those i will link them down in the
description
and in the pinned comment in this video
i will be covering
all the twists and turns from chapters 4
through 6 which were definitely the most
exciting
chapters yet i may have to bundle
multiple chapters in a single video just
because we are covering so many
different series here on the channel on
a weekly basis
and sometimes i just run out of time but
whenever there is a really big chapter
i will definitely cover it right away so
stay tuned
first up let's talk about percival's
hidden magic which was revealed for the
first time in chapters 3
and 4. percival did not even realize
that he had any magic
but during his battle against pelgart
something awoke
inside of him and then a strange magic
power began to flow around his
fists pelgart is fascinated by this
magic and he wants to learn more about
it
but percival is more shocked than anyone
that this magic
suddenly appeared so he couldn't really
explain what's going on
even if he wanted to whatever percival's
magic is it is definitely extremely
strong
as soon as it makes contact with pelgart
it sends him
flying and crashing to the ground but it
turns out that pelgard has been holding
back
this entire time and now he finally
begins to show percival some of his own
true power the black knight pelgard can
use
powerful fire magic to shoot fireballs
at his opponents
and he soon creates a deadly inferno
that percival is forced
to dodge over and over again i have to
say that this battle between purcell and
pelgard
is actually really good so i definitely
recommend checking out
the whole thing the manga is available
on crunchyroll
in their manga section and it comes out
weekly so if you're a crunchyroll member
you already have access to the manga
and to its official translations this is
not a sponsored video i'm just giving
you guys a heads up
pelkart manages to engulf percival's
entire body
with his flames and it doesn't look good
for percival
as his body begins to burn up but
then percival manages to extend his
magic energy from just his fists to the
rest of his body
essentially he envelops himself in his
own magic
and this provides a defensive coating
against pelgard's flames
percival then reveals another aspect of
his magic
a bunch of cute little chibi golems of
percival begin to emerge
out of his magical energy and they all
start swarming pelgard
it doesn't seem like percival is using
these magic abilities consciously this
appears to be like an
instinctual response the little golems
seem to understand that pelgard's flame
attack will be
undone if they can restrain his arms and
that is exactly what they proceed
to do with the flame spell undone
percival is now free but his body
is severely burned pelgard believes that
percival has already been defeated due
to the extent of his injuries
but then suddenly percival's magic
begins to
heal his body pelgart is shocked by how
overpowered percival's magic is and
eventually he comes to the conclusion
that the type of magic that percival
possesses is an extremely rare
one in a million magic called hero type
magic pelgart realizes that if he
possesses such an incredible magic type
then percival might be one of the
prophesized four knights of the
apocalypse
and in chapter 5 this is indeed
confirmed pelgart admits that percival
is extremely strong
especially since he learned to control
his magic so quickly after it appeared
but as it turns out pelgard was pulling
a frieza the whole time
final four my ass he wasn't even using
half of his full power and donnie tells
percival to just
run away because he has no real chance
of winning don even tries to buy
percival some time by using his magic to
force pelgard to levitate
but pelgard's fire magic overwhelms the
levitation
and nearly burns down the entire village
in the process
just as it looks like both donnie and
percival are about to be taken down by
pelgart
that strange fox shows up once again
and what's more the fox is dragging
percival's bag behind it
the fox then uses some sort of magic
ball a cursed ball to teleport
itself percival and donny away from the
black knight
the three of them find themselves on top
of a dragon's spine
these look to be the skeletal remains of
some massive
ancient dragon donny says that he's seen
this spine before
and that it is located like 30 miles
away from the village
percival wants to return to the village
and protect everyone from pelgart
but then that fox begins to speak
the fox tells percival not to be an
idiot and he says that pelgard wants
percival and donny so now that the two
of them are gone he won't bother anyone
else inside the village
both percival and doni are shocked that
an animal can talk
but the fox doesn't even bother
explaining why it can speak
it just tells percival that he has to
follow him because pelkart doesn't even
know where his father
is anyway so pelgard can't really help
him
the fox then says something crazy
apparently both pelgart and ironside
serve on evil king and as the fox
says this the image of this evil king
that we see
is clearly an image of king arthur
whoa like what king arthur is evil now
that would be a pretty insane twist but
i don't think it's true
i mean for one thing we know arthur and
he would never willingly become
evil and we also know that back on god's
finger
ironside had said something about
betraying king arthur
so i'm thinking that maybe these holy
knights betrayed
the real king arthur and either replaced
him with some fake king who is evil
or they cast some sort of possession
spell on arthur
and turned him evil against his will
either way though
if merlin is still with arthur i find it
difficult to believe that anyone would
have been able to manipulate him
so yeah all of this is highly sus
what in the world happened to merlin if
these holy knights
managed to pull one over on arthur this
is getting very interesting right about
now
and i can't wait to find out more
the fox then reveals that because of
that prophecy
the holy knights are determined to
locate and eradicate
the four nights of the apocalypse but
this legendary group of knights hasn't
even been
formed yet they are prophesied to appear
in the future and the holy knights want
to take them out
before they ever get a chance to fulfill
the prophecy
we then see an image of the four knights
of the apocalypse and it is clear that
percival is the night of death lancelot
is the night of war tristan is the
knight of plague
and the fourth knight the knight of
starvation
is still unknown technically but it's
most likely the child of
king and diane allegedly these four
knights of the apocalypse
will one day destroy the whole world by
releasing their plagues upon it
but as i said before that prophecy is
probably
highly misleading these four knights are
definitely the good guys
the heroes of the story and the fact
that the shady holy knights are after
them
only proves that point further and so we
arrive at chapter 6
which makes everything even crazier by
revealing the dark truth about
camelot as we know camelot was destroyed
during the final arcs of the seven
deadly sins manga
and so at the end of the series arthur
set out to rebuild his kingdom
but as it turns out 16 years later
camelot
is not what we thought it would be it
seems that camelot is now
inside a strange gravity-defying space
created by the power of chaos and to top
that off
it seems to be guarded by gigantic
demonic beings
pelgart enters this chaotic realm in
order to meet with the other holy
knights
they have all been summoned because a
new prophecy about the four knights of
the apocalypse has just been discovered
and this new information could prove to
be useful in their mission to hunt down
and destroy
these four knights ironside is there at
the meeting as well
as are a bunch of other cool and creepy
looking knights
some sort of dark wizard guy who is
hiding his appearance behind a cloak
reveals that the four knights of the
apocalypse are all young boys
at this point in time and they have some
clues
on who each one of them might be one
is a boy with holiness and evil in his
eyes
this is definitely tristan since he has
different colored eyes and his parents
are a goddess and a demon
one is a mysterious lad with no fixed
appearance
one is a boy bearing gold colored magic
and the final one is a child with
wing-like hair
this final one is obviously percival but
i'm not sure about the other two
lancelot has gold colored hair but is he
the one who has gold colored magic
and then what about the one with no
fixed appearance
is he or she someone who can change
their appearance like
king could so maybe that's king and
deanne's son
or daughter my guess is probably yes but
we'll have to wait and see
it's also highly likely that this fox is
somehow connected to bonn and lancelot
since bonn
is the fox's sin of greed i don't think
it's a coincidence that this mysterious
fox appeared when it did
and once we learned the fox's name it
becomes even more suspicious
another interesting point is that there
seems to be a group out there somewhere
that opposes these holy knights of
camelot
and this group is also looking for the
four knights of the apocalypse
the holy knights of camelot are
determined to find the four
first before their opponents can get
their hands on the mysterious
knights of prophecy after that big
meeting
pelgart and ironside have a little chat
outside
ironside claims that he thought he had
killed percival
but pelgart is suspicious ironside is
known as
ironside the assassin so it's very sus
that he somehow failed to take out one
of his targets
and what do you know that particular
target turned out to be his own
son pelgar tells ironside that percival
is indeed alive and that he has
impressive talents
according to pelgart killing percival
would be a waste
and they should just bring him under
their wing instead
but ironside insists that percival must
be killed
he is not just a threat to kick arthur
as one of the knights of the apocalypse
he is a threat to the entire world
according to the prophecy the four
knights of the apocalypse are going to
destroy
the world again i'm not buying it but
let's move on
back on top of the dragon's spine
percival refuses to accept what the fox
is saying
he is not going to become some world
destroying knight
the fox claims that the prophecy is 100
true
but he doesn't really care either way
the fox was ordered by someone to bring
percival
along with him and he knows exactly
where percival's father is
he is in camelot percival obviously
doesn't know anything about camelot so
the fox explains that it is a kingdom
which was destroyed 16 years ago
king arthur merlin and their loyal
followers went
into hiding and although camelot still
exists
you cannot get there by normal means
this must be referring to that
chaos realm camelot is currently located
inside some sort of special realm
created by chaos power
so there must be some special way of
actually
reaching it the fox says that in order
to reach camelot
you need to travel to the kingdom of
leones first
and percival agrees to follow the fox to
leonis
the fox then reveals that its real name
is sin
and along with donny the two of them set
out on the long
200 mile journey to leones
whoa i don't know about you guys but i
loved
these latest chapters and this is
getting really good
the first three chapters were solid but
these latest chapters have taken it up
to a whole new level
in my opinion and i am excited i can't
wait to find out what's really
going on with king arthur merlin and
camelot and not only that
but we are going to leones you know what
that means
we are definitely going to see some of
our old friends from the original series
again
very soon and that is awesome
also the fact that this fox's name is
sin come on this fox has to be connected
to bond
somehow and i can't wait to find out
what that connection is
definitely let me know what you guys
think did king arthur really turn
evil or is there some trickery going on
also
are the four knights of the apocalypse
really going to destroy the world
personally i think that's bs or at least
it's really misleading
they are not going to destroy the world
but maybe they are going to destroy the
status quo
and change the world for the better or
something like that
this all reminds me of the beginning of
the seven deadly sins
at first the sins were portrayed as
dangerous outlaws and traitors
but they turned out to be the good guys
who were framed by the bad guys
i'm guessing some similar bait and
switch will happen with this
prophecy and the knights of the
apocalypse so
are you guys enjoying the story as much
as i am and are you excited to see what
happens next
are you excited for leonis let me know
down below
if you enjoyed this video and you want
to see more seven deadly sins
and nights of the apocalypse videos
right here on the channel please leave a
like to let me know
it really does help and if you're new to
anime pro or maybe you watch our videos
but you haven't subscribed yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications you really have to go
through the trouble of subscribing
hitting that bell and then selecting the
option that says all
it's annoying but unless you do that
you're still gonna miss a ton of our
videos even if you are subscribed it's
just how youtube works
you can also hit me up on twitter and
instagram
at animeopror a big thank you to all of
our anime outpour patrons for making
videos like this one possible
special thank you to alpha sigma
disciple of lord twigo himself
and i can't forget all of our the one
tier patrons the ones who rise above
all other clans including ingrata
the world a quiet respect pate heffa
liam thompson
aldital dr cortman johnny boy draws
emperor otaku spidey life canal big
buddhist and tungsten tarkis
finally thank you also to our pro hero
tier patrons including the one and only
gilgamesh steelers on hell crews anatoly
kazatsky
joe stanton very gucci jessica califond
rathune de ora alicia octor bonnie parks
hinokami and water the red-haired raven
joanne garcia jack watches anime fat boy
games ted no ted deadly saint matthew
cruz and
anthony schreiber if you enjoy our
videos and you feel that they provide
value for you consider supporting us
on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patreon exclusive
discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these
amazing people as always thank you guys
so much for watching and until next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you